Vous le connaissez tous.
Il devine sans jamais se tromper ce à quoi vous pensez,
son nom est A....
...Ki.....
T'es hyper relou avec ta musique épique de merde !
Woléeeeeee !!!
Ok, ok je me présente je m'appelle Henri . Moi c'est Lucas, Hauchard.
Vous voyez ce génie qui sort de sa lampe et qui sourit à tous les gens qui vont sur son p***** de site web,
on va le faire redencendre sur terre un peu parce que là hé *siffle*
tu redescends Akinator !! Jouer
Fais deviner des personnages, ou fais deviner des objets, animaux, concepts,
ahhh, il fait le tri direct d'office le mec !!
Pas tant un génie que ça.
Tu vas deviner un personnage mon gars.
Pense à un personnage réel ou fictif. Je vais tenter de le deviner.
Bonne chance cousin...
Age : j'ai 93 ans. Qu'est ce-que ça peut te foutre !!!
Ton personnage est-il de sexe féminin ?
Non
Il a un téléphone portable ?
Je sais pas !!
Existe-t-il réellement ??
Non
Porte-t-il la moustache ?
A-t-il des cheveux ?
Non
Est-il issu d'un jeu vidéo ?
Est-il jaune ??
Oui
Ton personnage écrit-il des romans gay ?
Quoi ?! Non
Ton personnage est-il enseignant ?
Je pense à Koro-sensei
Noooooon !!!!!
On t'as grillé Koro, vas-t-en, vas-t-en
Ok, Ok ,on passe aux choses sérieuses
Effectivement, il est très fort ce "génie"
Ton personnage a-t-il des cheveux ?
Non
Aboie-t-il ?
Peut-il voler ?
Non
Est-il un Pokémon ?
Bien tenté gamin avec la sortie de Pokémon GO.
Est-il un animal ?
Non
Porte-il des vêtements ?
Est-il gentil ?
Non
Est-il méchant ??
oui
Est-il issu de l'animation Japonaise ?
Mais pourquoi tout de suiteuuh !!
Oui
Est-il géant ?
Est-il rouge ?
Oui
A-t-il des tentacules ?
Ah non !! Ah là non
A-t-il une queue ?
Pfff..non
Est-il complètement chauve ?
Ouais
Le Titan Colossal
Putain, m****
On arrête avec tout ce qui est Japonais
On va passer sur une autre thématique où il a moins de facilité
Rejouer
Ton personnage aboie-t-il ?
Non
A-t-il des cheveux ?
Oui
Est-il issu de l'animation japonaise ?
Nan !
A-t-il réellement existé ?
Oui
Parle-t-il couramment français ?
Non
Est-il décédé ?
Sexe féminin ? Non
A-t-il eu un rapport avec le milieu du sport ?
Non
Est-il un acteur ?
T'as du mal à trouver petit c** !!!
Fait-il de la politique ?
Et bah non !!! Hein !!
Parle-t-il l'anglais ?
Probablement
A-t-il plus de 35 ans ?
Oui
Est-il asiatique ?
Oui !
Fait-il partie du milieu du jeu vidéo ?
Oui !!
Est-il le créateur du personnage de Mario ?
Oui !
Je pense à Shigeru Miyamoto
Il est fort là ce, cet Indien là ! C'est un indien ??
P***** je pensais l'avoir feinté en disant qu'on avait arrêté avec tout ce qui est Japonais !
Il m'a bien eu le c** de fakir
Ou génie, c'est pareil
Ton personnage a-t-il des poils et quatre pattes ?
Non
Existe-t-il réellement ?
Porte-il des vêtements masculins ?
Oui
Est-il issu de l'animation Japonaise ?
Non !! Tu arrêtes maintenant
Fait-il des combats ?
Oui
Est-il masqué ?
Ça dépend
Porte-t-il une cape ?
Oui
Vit-il à Gotham ?
Et bah nan !! Et bah nan !!
Figure-t-il dans Star Wars ?
Non plus !!
Est-il issu d'un jeu vidéo ?
Oui
Monte-t-il à cheval ?
Nan
A-t-il une épée ?
Oui
Ton personnage a-t-il de près ou de loin un rapport avec Nintendo ?
Non !
Ton personnage a-t-il un rapport avec le jeu Dark Souls ?
*musique stressante* Oui
Ton personnage est-il le héros principal de l'oeuvre dans laquelle on le trouve ?
Oui
Je pense à ton personnage dans Dark Souls
M**** !!
Ok je sais,
Ouvrez bien vos oreilles !
Ton personnage fait-il partie du dessin animé Pokémon ?
Attend, le mec direct !
Ouais et alors !?
A-t-il un rapport avec les éclairs ?
Nan
Ton personnage vole-t-il ?
Ouais !
Est-il un Pokémon feu ?
Non
Il est légendaire ?
Non,
Hmmpf..t'as vraiment pas envie de l'avoir !!
A-t-il des ailes ?
Ouais
A-t-il un bec ?
C'est faux !
Ton personnage vole-t-il la nuit ?
Ouais
A-t-il la peau bleu ?
Je sais pas... *clin d'oeil*
Fait-il des vidéos en rapport avec Nintendo ?
*souffle nasal* J'sais pas !
Est-il encore célèbre aujourd'hui ?
Ouais
Est-il de petite taille ?
Oui
Je pense à Nostenfer !
Nan !! Nan !!
Eh bah non mon con !!
Tu sais pourquoi petit e***** ?
Alors ouais je pensais à Nostenfer ouais
Mais à Nostenfer shiny !!
Booooooooom !!!!!!
Akinator, tu l'as vu ? Mon cul !
Et voila les gens, c'est comme ça que l'on détruit un mythe,
un génie,
un Indien se cachant dans une lampe
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu,
et si on l'a bien niqué.
Chuis fier de moi,
bah ouais,
Il a..il..bah c'est pas de ma faute si il a pas pensé à...pensé au Pokémon shiny,
autrement appelé Pokémon chromatique,
eh ouais mon pote,
p***** je suis heureux.
J’espère que ça vous a plu, on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
Ça m'a bien fait marrer de, d'e****** à sec cet Akinator.
Et portez-vous bien chiao tout le monde peace !